se le hará un día de campo para sus seis
amigas a le tiene diez años diana tiene
seis años de edad tiene un total de 48
uvas estas son nuestras 48 uvas y busca
repartir las equitativamente entre ellas
cuántas uvas tendrá cada amiga vamos a
tomar la información que es básica
podemos saber que el día de campo será
entonces para
seis amigas
la edad de las amigas realmente no nos
interesa que tenga diez años y que diana
tenga seis no nos da información
relevante sin embargo si es relevante
saber que tiene un total de 48 uvas y
que busca repartir las equitativamente
entre ellas vamos a tener entonces
también 48 uvas
y a ustedes los invito a que ya con esta
información pausa en el vídeo y busquen
encontrar la forma de tener la respuesta
de cuántas uvas tendrá cada amiga
tomando en cuenta que tenemos 48 uvas y
son seis amigas vamos a reescribir esto
aquí
y borraré este 6 de aquí porque tenemos
48 uvas que será repartido entre 6
amigas
esto es una división 48 uvas entre 6
amigas esto cuánto nos dará y si
nosotros buscamos saber este signo de
interrogación podemos hacer lo siguiente
tomaremos las 48 uvas como referencia
y entonces sabremos que este signo de
admiración será igual a algún número que
es el que vamos a descubrir que esté
multiplicado por seis
es decir que 48 entre 6 nos dará este
número es lo mismo que decir que 48 es
igual a ese mismo número por 6 ok si
nosotros buscamos dentro de la tabla del
6 o los múltiplos del 6 podemos hacer lo
siguiente
buscaremos entonces qué número dentro de
la tabla del 6 nos puede dar 48 y
empecemos con 6 por 1
es igual a 6
6 por 2 es igual a 12 lo notan
únicamente estamos sumando aquí 6 más
6 por 3 es igual a 18
6 x 4 es igual a 24
6 x 5 es igual a 30
6 x 6 es igual a 36
6 x 7 es igual a 42 insisto sólo estamos
sumando de seis en seis para localizar
los múltiplos de 6
6 x 8 es igual a 48 tenemos el 48 ya
llegamos al 48
de esta manera sabemos de 6 por 8 es
igual a 48 o 48 entre 6 va a ser igual a
este 8 es el número que estábamos
buscando
así es que multiplicaremos entonces
por 6
y el resultado nos diría que cada una de
las amigas tendrá 8 uvas y para
comprobar esto tenemos aquí nuestras 48
uvas y vamos a hacer algo vamos a
dividir estas 48 uvas
seis grupos de ocho uvas cada uno es
decir que cada una de estas amigas podrá
tener uno de estos grupos de ocho uvas
tenemos aquí
8 uvas este es un primer grupo de 8
vamos a hacer otro grupo de 8
en nuestro segundo grupo de ocho un
tercer grupo de 8
el cuarto grupo de ocho uvas
y finalmente haremos aquí nuestro mejor
esfuerzo por tener este grupo ahora de 8
uvas
es importante que marquemos la
diferencia entre cada uno de estos
grupos
este será nuestro último grupo de ocho
uvas
de esta manera cada una de sus amigas
podrá tener uno de estos grupos de ocho
uvas y así cada una tendrá la misma
cantidad de uvas dentro de este día de
campo